I'll never say no to a cool job I don't
mind helping out when they need me to
for decades Raven Symone has charmed
audiences as an actress but in 2015 she
won us over by just being herself as a
co-host on the view I remember coming on
the view and I was 15 years old for the
Cheetah Girls even though she's been in
relationships with men she's also been
in relationships with women she doesn't
want to be labeled that sounds familiar
fast forward to 2020 and fans are
clamoring to see more of Raven on
daytime TV especially if it means a mini
Cheetah Girls reunion there are now not
one but there's two seats open on the
reel and knowing how close you are with
your girl Adrienne Bailon Houghton I'm
curious if that is something you'd ever
want to return to your daytime TV roots
I did hold up wait a man de Levy and
Tamera Mowry sleeping oh snap oh yeah
yeah so you're saying to others
I'm ready they're so great on the view
and you're so opinionated and have so
many great things to say is it is it a
conversation there's always
conversations to be had but I'm gonna
stay true to what I've been setting
goals for during Corona and that's to
focus on my skills as a director and EP
in a creator and really take what I've
learned in the industry and pass it
along to people that are beginning and
also using my skills to help shows
continue to grow but I'll never say no
to a cool job I don't mind helping out
when they need me to as long as we're
Corona safe I'm down for the cause but
my trajectory in my head now that I'm
married and you know soon that I start a
family and you know need to do that I
want to make sure I'm getting into a job
position that allows me time to myself
because let's not forget how demanding
that job was before Corona and I'm sure
it's demanding
this is gonna sound egotistical but you
know the demand that's needed for me and
the jobs as I've been in have taken my
life to where I have not had a personal
life it is you know morning tonight we
need you we need you you need you and
I'm like I'm trying to cuddle so I don't
know how that's gonna work well I mean
you just said you're thinking about
everything Emily is that happening in
the near future I mean we just got
married everyone talks about it then
right yeah I get I got married in
October so it's always a conversation
it's always calm yeah last month the
Ravens Homestar surprised the world when
she revealed she married her girlfriend
social media manager Miranda mad a what
he liked the rest of us your wife was
she a fan of your work growing up no
really why she didn't watch the shows
there she's a different mind which is
what attracted me to her she watched a
lot of cooking show she watched a lot of
documentaries
she watched like friends and things of
that nature I don't think she went to
the Disney Channel she knew of me but
that's you know she didn't really she
didn't grow up with me yep that's me the
triple threats latest project a Disney
Channel crossover Ravens home is
colliding with bunked for one epic
special called
what else Raven about Punk'd it's gonna
be the best summer ever are we honest
there GPS has been recalculating welcome
to camp kikiwaka it's a big deal
honestly this is the first crossover in
a very long time we love seeing both of
these shows go on adventures so for them
to do a massive one is insane film this
episode before the pandemic and you know
we knew it was gonna air but we didn't
realize it was gonna air at such a time
when entertainment is needed I'm excited
to be able to say that I work with
Miranda and the cast of bunks because
they have been going strong on Disney
Channel for many years and it feels so
good to sit next to my Disney sisters
and it makes them content it feels great
[Music]